so can we can we talk about how uh the
stonker market can we talk about the
stock market that's
uh that we've recently just seen yeah
we're going to be very delayed
we are going to be very delayed because
it's so worried so what's it just
happened to us it's just happened or is
is happening
i don't [ __ ] know it's a constantly
evolving situation by so
by the time this airs it's probably
everything we're probably going to be
saying is going to be outdated
yeah um who knows the stock market might
not even exist by the time yeah
my god when reality is this entertaining
who the [ __ ] needs tv this is what i'm
saying this is what i've always said
real life is so much more interesting
yeah and you couldn't make a movie about
like if you pitched a movie being like
right so what happens is a bunch of
redditors right
they buy gamestop stock and they like
they [ __ ] over these billion dollar head
like no no everyone thinks that's
[ __ ] stupid yeah
it happens yeah this is the coolest
[ __ ] story yeah yeah
plus documentaries are better than
movies yeah and i just think we
are reaching a time period where you
know it used to be
you know a funny meme but now memes are
just
real-life memes big memes now are
basically just
making fun of like real-life events yeah
you know and having a real life
effect on the world that is that is the
modern that is what memes are growing
inside i think i think i saw someone on
twitter saying though like
this is like kind of the revitalization
of it's just a prank bro but
the pranks are just like gone actually
gone far like
gone wrong yeah i'm not gonna lie the
first time i saw that story i was like
i don't know what the [ __ ] is happening
and i'm really scared to ask
dude i i like when it was happening i
was like what the [ __ ] does shorting a
stock mean
yeah and now i'm just like now because
of this meme i've done so much research
that i'm just like
maybe i should get into the stock market
you know
it's it's it's really weird because i
have not your life now
that youtube look i'm not i'm not a
gambling addict okay as much as
as much as the gadget episode uh might
have it might have made me like i am not
a gambling addict
on gotcha but not but it's made me think
a lot about my you know grown-up
investment
like uh grown-up investments uh talk
that i just well
because i've been doing stocks like
through like
my dad because my dad is like really
missing so i've been doing it but
when this [ __ ] happened i was like sh
should i be scared
what's happening i don't know what that
dad is
daddy please is my money okay please
yeah i mean no one no one in my family
has anything about it i mean yeah
you know i think my my family always i
think every single generation of my
family is just like made enough to get
by
right yeah do buy some nice things here
and there yeah so
they don't think stocks was ever on
their mind i think my my parents had
some stocks in the companies they worked
for as like a gift
right yeah so i think my dad checks up
on those stocks but in terms of actually
knowing about the stock market
yeah you know my no one in my family has
any idea well right because it's not
something that you know everyone
commonly learns
right but that's that's that's what i
was thinking
fancy gambling for richmond yeah well
that's that's what it's
like marketed as right but i mean i'm
doing my research and like
probably probably reading into this um
you know like i was thinking
why the [ __ ] aren't we taught this in
school because i feel like
especially knowledge on the stock market
a lot of the reasons why people don't
get into the stock market
from what i've realized is because
nobody knows [ __ ] about it it's it's
because no
nobody was taught this in school and it
sounds so complicated that nobody has
the effort or energy to really
read up and learn about this i mean i
didn't and the only reason
i started reading about up about this
was because the [ __ ] stock market was
on fire and it turned into a massive
meme
i literally started reading up about
this
because of a meme who i thought that
memes get you to go into like
educational adventures happens all the
time man
but like what what this made me think
was why wouldn't we talk about this in
school like there's so many
growing up there's so many life
essential like knowledge that i think
should be
that i think everyone should know to be
fair though it's like i'm thinking back
like when you were like 15
14 right you wouldn't pay attention you
wouldn't have paid attention no
i mean you wouldn't they always say like
oh why didn't they teach kids about
taxes in school as well because i don't
think they're happy
no one would [ __ ]
even with taxes i do think that there
should have been something yeah no
i agree there should be something so at
least you when you get to that point in
life
you are aware and you can go back to be
like oh this is why it was important
because there's there's so many things
like for example i don't know why
they're
like it's not compulsory to have a
financial management course
in in in in school they should be they
should they
should be because financial management
is such an as like an
adult life essential skill and it's
something that you have to learn
by just by just either one your parents
teaching it to you
or two [ __ ] up and realizing that
this is an important skill you need to
know
instead of schools are like no let's
learn the quadratic equation yeah but
we'll need that but no
let's learn that beautiful actually yeah
you're doing it on the quadratic
equation
let's let's let's learn that there are
180 degrees in the triangle
i've used that before in my life let's
learn about the tangents and the
cosine
well you know i think i think why they
should be teaching
like taxes and financial advice in
school is not so that like
you get because obviously kids aren't
gonna [ __ ] come out of school being
like hello let me do your taxes yeah
just so that when they leave school it's
like it's on the back of their mind
like i've been taught that this is a
thing that's going to come up and that i
should learn how it works
for my value yeah exactly it's the whole
point of school i feel should be
at least preparing you for what you're
going to face in the adult world and you
know there can be some specialized
courses yeah i
i i mean it up but i can understand why
they teach mathematics and algebra in
case you want to
pursue that right what i am saying is
there are so many
life essential knowledge that i had to
learn on the fly and everyone does and i
was just not taught this stuff in school
and i'm thinking
why the [ __ ] is this not taught in
school yeah and the thing is is that
like yeah you know people can argue
being like you know oh
who needs to know the [ __ ] quadratic
equation what people are going to like
architecture or like math-based stuff
but like yeah
financial advice and taxes you're like
that it doesn't matter what job you go
into
you're gonna have to deal with it as an
adult yeah i mean it's like
there's so many things in my school that
we were taught that like
were replaceable in my mind like we were
taught like
we were like dude like media studies and
like where we just like analyze like
newspapers and [ __ ] and just like talked
about like the media and how they
advertise this stuff
it's in my job now but i didn't even get
anything useful from that yeah i i had
to do that as well yeah it was fun
and then i did like cooking which was
stupid because i'm
let's be honest i'm not a good cook as
i'm sure guys will finally
be honest be honest
make money get over easy that's what
it's all about yeah no but like you
could have replaced it and i think that
um
[ __ ] what was i going to say [ __ ] i
totally forgot my point now [ __ ] i'm
done
go back to you i'll i'll i'll figure it
out okay okay no i'm i'm just saying
like there's so many
important things in life that i just
don't know about like
you know like for example i have no idea
about anything about mortgages or
anything like that and when i say
mortgage
you say the word mortgage right and
you're like oh okay you are grown up
but you know you know yeah as a kid you
hear the word mortgage you're just like
i don't need to worry about that yeah
that's grown-ups i had to learn that
[ __ ] on the fly i was like i don't know
what the [ __ ]
the thing is everyone should you know
aim to own a house or own some property
that's like the
one of the final goals in life right and
yeah it's no
nobody's taught this [ __ ] isn't it bad
the only time i've ever heard the word
mortgage was in a monopoly game
that's the only time i've heard of and
and you know well i still would have no
i still don't know how to mortgage in a
monopoly game yeah
exactly i i still i still have like the
bare bones basic idea about a mortgage
because
i've i've not gone through the process
of buying house because that [ __ ] sounds
scary to me yeah it is
and i i did go and see uh uh mortgage
advice
just because i wanted to learn more
about it and my bank had it for like
they were like free
consultations i had no intention of
getting a mortgage i don't even know how
they work
yeah because i feel like you should know
yeah yeah so i i went and then
just really awkward thing of like so
what do you what do you do and like
and i'm like oh well well you see uh so
i make make videos about like anime this
is the time and
he was like okay and he was like and
like this is your this is your income
and i was like yeah and he's like
it changed a lot in one year i'm like
yeah yeah it does that
it could go up or down i don't know i'm
not thinking i should just tell him as
little about my job as possible this
guy's a
financial risk you can't give him a
mortgage but yeah i mean it was it was
it was
pretty standard stuff i mean there's
different rates and stuff but
yeah i mean i i had to sit down with
like al like family financial advisor he
basically like i had to go through like
that's the most
privileged thing you've ever said
i have never had a holy financial no
it's because it's because my
my parents are like super into like
[ __ ] like the housing market and like
the stock market and [ __ ] like that so
it's just like
you're an adult now you still sounds
privileged you can you can talk to this
man in a suit that
comes to our house every so often you
think is our lawyer i used to call him
our lawyer because i didn't know who the
[ __ ] this guy was i was like there's a
man in a suit he must be a lawyer
check your wealth